how's it going best my name is that's me
milking your nips what welcome back to
octopus desk
goddamnit whoa we actually changed our
[ __ ] thing
what are we doing here this is what
we're gonna do oh god damn it
really he doesn't even give a [ __ ] I
thought he would react to the shake or
something
whoa dem skillz that's a taste we
escaped can really give up now what
what's happening how does this over in
the underwater tank okay I got it man
sharks are such oh god is that it's
[ __ ] creepy one is that one gonna eat
the shark oh God
yep it's it's a really like nice and
charming game but it has a really like
depressing undertone with the problem
with the wife or whatever I really hope
it gets to resolve nicely I mean
obviously it's got oh god damn it oh oh
that's all I got it there whoever built
that is an idiot
ow see I can dis link through she's I am
had a lame man his name was saying oh
god damn it's you again scheisse where
the hell are we
oh oh so she'll since the what Oh
Naughton what why are they no normals
yet I think the wife is gonna find out
that we're in octopus and she's gonna
get just get super turn-on like she is
into really [ __ ] weird anime [ __ ] and
stuff I think that that's that's but
damn I'm not sure I'm like 99% sure I
mean he can't go on living the lie the
real question is how the [ __ ] kids
got to life maybe their adopted mother
it's almost closing time
no no I saw him go in a weird door
another mystery
well well wait as long as we can
well that's awkward excuse me ma'am I
have bad news about your husband don't
trust him have we met
wait yeah I've seen you it's him are you
an old friend of my husband's what can
you tell me about him everything you
must come with me to cafeteria come on
Stacy why can't he just tell MA
I think that's a pretty good spot to
tell him just sayin a blob of getting
his game face on how do you blob you a
game face
Oh got it why do I even try oh okay [ __ ]
god damn it oh there we go we're fine
yeah dad dad don't don't [ __ ] with me
now pipe don't write I need to get this
guy's Ishak like watching Tom I'm a DA
mind me I'm just an octopus they didn't
see me what the [ __ ] haha oh that
camouflage that [ __ ] self camouflage
objective Bieber what what are they
doing in the cafeteria after it's closed
anyway why am i [ __ ] the railings stop
I [ __ ] me you dirty [ __ ]
I made it oh my god I don't know how I
did it but I'd [ __ ] did it okay let's
go in the tiny hole that's what she said
okay he's someone said it okay just shut
up
okay I'm stop this is why I hate
sandwiches yeah and I have nothing to
win
thing you hear something coming from the
break room yeah it's probably just Joe
why do you all look identical Sally the
salmon are you not yet he said okay hey
Sally you're free you're free Sally I
should start a fire
got it I know sorry Sally but I got a I
got a cookie all right Sally
yup it's blazing flames I'm just a fish
like you you got to learn how to let go
I can't feel my tips this is ridiculous
you don't go in there and make sure he's
all right okay what do I do now
oh I got to leave the break room Pat it
take one step at a time okay what is
that I'm stuck to something aren't I
yeah
what is it now what what am i stuck oh I
hold on to the table ha ha I'm sorry
just get sucked in you little [ __ ] dude
seriously night ok thank God thank God
okay Oh God Oh shrimp what is happening
here oh my god all right now we can go
to the cafeteria won't figure he makes
this huge mess then splits hey yes Joe a
break he probably had to get home to his
wife
who the [ __ ] is Joe anyway okay what's
going on Rick what are they doing with
that glass what is that a shark costume
well that's his [ __ ] splendid okay
alright so what do we want to do is we
want to grab on to introduce this new
sweet okay after what that tech oh jeez
sorry help I'm wet alright so now we
just have to watch out for that one guy
over there no more card jeez
so now what's that how does he see me
how the hell am I supposed to go
yes okay on the count of three one suck
it in
now you'll never say me just a guard
really how is this gonna help I'm wrong
oh how was your day oh maybe just our
Joe huh [ __ ] you guys let's go on in
we really need to buy stronger glass
with a piranha tank this happens every
day
hey guys good today's eight yeah we did
it yeah I know what the [ __ ] I'm stack
how oh no no no no you not get it
he was also for me no why would he does
it make any sense how would he even walk
yeah you're stores
I'm not crazy clearly
I guess you don't know anything after
all well then we're leaving it's past
the kids bedtime you not leaving until
you understand what he's like look at my
dick I know it I know ha ha ha ha oh
just because you're right doesn't mean
you're not crazy
this explains so much
you have them because it's so turned on
that she fainted would I still caught
you dog oh no now I'm a cooked octopus
fry dog don't post call me off - he
wanna kill me like what the hell did I
ever did it how that legit hurts
alright I got it
I'm running like a pony's ass god damn
it that's hard ponies don't run god damn
I didn't teach a medium stupid do you
even know what it's ponies okay you need
to shut up okay I can just run across
apparently that's oh god dammit not to
banana peel not now cowboy why does
bananas hate me what the hell how the
hell did he do that that is indeed a
power takedown what how what that [ __ ]
Oh Stacey is on the other end of the
cafeteria be careful there
step lightly of course it will not
matter you will fail this epic music
what the [ __ ] is this okay okay what did
I do it I think I did it
how the hell did I do it
oh [ __ ]
boom headshot okay plug your three fists
paths
myth me [ __ ] come on
oh so close ah banana no no my greatest
enemy an entire will stop with a banana
spaceman please just yes this thing is
gonna blow hope so hey I hope he dies
please I please die a horrible death
wait how the what ha ha that's
disgusting
yeah what is happening right now it's
called a boner
just go with it baby look whoa really
forgive me even for you
hey guess I'm your family really loves
you all focus I not bother you again
well that [ __ ] turkey aired I get it
had a boner too honey
so this news will take some getting used
to but I was imagining much worse like
what yeah time tell me 10 years earlier
wait a second
if that is an octopus then then where
did me and Stacey come from
why it's so funny seriously yeah
seriously the lead actor is dreamy okay
right yeah it's like a big it's the plot
of all time
oh oh well I really really like that
game I I have a lot of fun with it from
the beginning to end this is this a
straight-up
funny game I'm really I really want to
check out the coop I think they'll be
fun - I'm not to do with someone yeah
and nobody should smash the thing oh
that's how it's [ __ ] awesome and
they're all leaving oh I can't go okay
there was no secret ending well [ __ ] me
let's go you're not going anyway be okay
I guess you are okay hahaha oh nice
alright so that was after that hope you
guys enjoyed like if you enjoyed this
series let me know it what do you want
me to see me play next it really means a
lot to me that you bros watch this
series i it's these that I feel more
than ever that we're actually like
playing together so I think it's pretty
cool anyway stay awesome bros see in the
next one
hey yeah seen that ok see you in the